we'll see performances of each female
written track in the original song
category including beyonce's be alive
from king richard
[Music]
queen b will belt it out likely from a
local tennis court today we got a look
at the neon green surfaces freshly
painted for the rumored performance an
eyewitness told e.t beyonce filmed here
this past sunday
i'm wondering what you're going to
create for beyonce beyonce going beyonce
listen there you go
becky g and luis fonzie will sing
encantos we don't talk about bruno which
was not nominated why
if there is a song that unites people
this year that is kind of the epitome
[Music]
you are performing at the oscars for the
first time in over 30 years how you
feeling i feel really good about it
[Music]
four good days was a wonderful message
of hope as the song is
somehow you do
gives hope reba mcintyre told me how
she's prepping for hollywood's biggest
night i haven't been able to eat for the
last four months getting ready for this
i'm losing my covered weight and it was
sure a lot more fun and a lot easier to
gain than it is to get rid of
reba turned 67 on monday and the
country's superstar just released my
chains are gone an album of hymns and
gospels it's very inspirational i think
it'll be good for a lot of people's
hearts and you have your friends trisha
yearwood and kelly clarkson on it as
well means the world to me that's what
friends are for you know i i went to
sing with trisha and kelly on her
christmas special and i said hey girls
let's do it on my special here they come
so now it's trisha's turn so whenever
she's ready whether it's going playing
poker at their house or go sing a song
with her on television or on stage we're
there for her
[Music]
did you have a chance to see kelly's
cover of i will always love you at the
acms because i am still i have it on
repeat every day i did i saw it you
think watching her sing is a thrill
you talk about intimidating we did a
tour together years ago that girl could
sing the phone book and i'd sit there
and listen to every word
i'll bring the pizza next week let me
know what kind of toppings you want so
we'll celebrate your birthday ham and
pineapple will be fine thank you no
you're a pineapple
some woman
i love it speaking of food there will be
plenty for the stars at the oscars
official after party the governor's ball
my daughter had an important question
which was
is there going to be cake for this
celebration
more like home cooked food like fried
chicken with waffles chef wolfgang puck
gave e.t a preview of the 40 different
dishes and there will be lots of bubbly
and tequila 30 cases just for the
governor's ball 2 000 bottles a lot of
champagne for everyone to enjoy
[Music]
you